[Music]
and all you members of the Trump ad
media we know you're watching well let's
start with a little news flash for you
President Trump did not let me repeat
did not fire the special counsel Robert
Muller so all of you rigid radical
left-wing ideologues you need to take a
collective deep breath or xanax or a
drink whatever works better now you can
take it and you can breathe in through
the nose and out through the mouth and
see if you can stop with your hysteria
you're breathless reporting this rampant
speculation and I want you to listen
closely President Trump he did not fire
the Special Counsel Robert Muller in
fact the president and his legal team
have been more than cooperative they
have voluntarily handed over 20,000
pages to the special counsel in total
Robert Muller has collected 1.4 million
pages of documents from the campaign and
then there's this according to the New
York Times and other liberal media
outlets president Trump demanded Robert
Muller be fired but Fox News Tonight is
reporting the president did not order
Muller to be removed instead there was
just a conversation back in June about
the possibility given Muller's massive
conflicts of interest this is why last
night I did not and will never in the
future trust the New York Times because
they have gotten it wrong time after
time after time and it's why President
Trump is ripping the so-called paper of
record let's take a look thank you sir
thank you
New York Times big story see facts truth
we've been telling you for a long time
it doesn't matter to the liberal
mainstream media and it's why last night
when the New York Times posted their
story about ten minutes till show time
for this show the media goes into a
frenzy they're foaming at the mouth they
completely lost it it's funny on the one
hand but sad because journalism is dead
what's this the President of the United
States tried to fire the Independent
Counsel Robert Muller the third does
that rise to the level of an impeachable
offense there's always been a question
of whether or not Donald Trump is simply
ignorant or whether he's corrupt I think
the more information we get you sort of
lean toward corrupt love all things
Donald Trump through his first year in
office has done everything possible to
undermine obstruct demean and halt this
legitimate investigation it adds to the
mounting evidence that there is a
serious obstruction case here I don't
know how this movie ends but there was a
lot of bloodshed in The Godfather and
this is gonna be a rough year
it is so pathetically predictable from
the news media you know what they never
waste an opportunity to smear this
president peddle fake news they don't
care any longer about the truth that
said now their singular goal is to
damage destroy President Trump you can
see an hour in hour out day in day out
minute by minute it's why the media has
been getting caught in the wrong
countless times so-called major news
stories let's give you a few examples
just from last year remember fake news
CNN the whole network while they falsely
reported that Donald Trump jr. received
an email by WikiLeaks in advance of
their release of the DNC emails and
other documents well it turned out that
fake News CNN well they got the date of
the email totally wrong it came one day
after WikiLeaks made the DNC documents
public number ABC's Brian Ross
spectacularly wrong when he reported the
former national security advisor General
Michael Flynn that he was going to
testify the president Trump ordered him
during the campaign to contact Russian
officials oh that fake news actually
tanked the stock market
and Ross then had to issue a correction
saying oh it happened during the
transition which means he was talking to
a future counterpart a huge difference
now Ross was suspended and is now banned
from even covering president Trump I can
think of a lot of other people that
should be banned as well now we also
have a totally dishonest Washington Post
reporter this is David Weigel and he
posts a picture from President Trump's
recent rally showing that little tiny
itsy-bitsy crowd and the caption reads
packed to the rafters here's the problem
that picture is deceptive because it was
taken before most people had gotten in
there and why go later
well I'm sorry why go later have
apologized and deleted the tweet
whoopsie-daisy well that's your media at
its finest at work and by the way those
are only a few of the many examples of
epic fake news screw-ups and anonymous
sourcing of course it's why the New York
Times you know they report about robert
muller
and the media is over the top the sky is
falling down hysteria coverage
breathless Rick coverage well it's not
surprising for over a year they have
been pushing conspiracy theories they
have been chasing ghosts about Trump
Russia collusion and we still have no
evidence now meanwhile the media has
been completely oblivious to the biggest
stories it's right there of their
lifetime and from what we've seen it's
shaping up to be the biggest scandal in
American history and they have missed
the boat now this is going to make
Watergate look like an afterthought and
only a fraction of the information is
yet to come out we have been uncovering
and reporting night after night on
massive severe constitutional abuses
that were committed by top ranking Obama
DOJ FBI officials against the Trump
campaign new evidence is also showing
that the Clinton email investigation
was a total sham it was rigged the fix
was in and tonight we have new text
messages from corrupt Trump bashing FBI
lovers Peter struck and Lisa Paige in a
new exchange it appears the couple was
leaking information about the Clinton
email investigation to the media look at
the date just before the election
October 28th 2016 after news broke that
the FBI
Uma Aberdeen's emails on creepy anthony
Weiner's laptop computer lisa page
writes well still on with Devlin
political is saying that's now
Washington Post reporter Devlin Barrett
and page finishes Mike's phone is on
fire struck responds it's on the news
then adds you may want to tell Devlin he
should turn on CNN there's news going on
and struck also says sorry and then page
replies he knows he just got handed a
note and struck says ha he's asking
about it now and pages yeah it was
pretty funny coming now now minutes
after those texts are said Devlin
Barrett then writes on Twitter sources
are telling him that emails on weiners
computer might not be new and instead
were just copies of Clinton emails that
the FBI has already looked at now we
reached out to the reporter and he told
us no comment shocking so we have what
looks like leaks from page and struck
and there's so many more 50,000 total
this is only the tip of the iceberg
let's go back to February 25th 2016 look
at this page messaging her boyfriend
struck one more thing she might be our
next president the last thing you need
is us going in there loaded for bear he
thinks she's gonna remember or care that
it was more DOJ than FBI and struck
replies agreed so in February struck in
Page are actually saying they're worried
about actually investigating Clinton
because she might end up being mad at
them and may want revenge if she wins
because they think she's going to win
and they're trying to help her then just
months later in May remember was James
Comey and struck and other key FBI
officials they started writing Clinton's
exoneration statement this is months
before interviewing her and 17 other key
witnesses when do you write an
exoneration before an investigation now
this is where they change the language
remember from the legal standard gross
negligence is a crime they take that out
they put an extreme carelessness means
the same thing but legally a very big
distinction well that means they give
Clinton to get out of jail free card
then they also altered language about
far
actors likely hacking Clinton's server
that puts people's lives at risk and
they removed a reference to Clinton
emailing with then President Obama which
means he knew about the server that
means he needs to be investigated that
means he needs to be put under oath so
in other words the fix on the email
server scandal was in now remember any
of these issues that we're talking about
with the email server scandal they're
all crimes mishandling classified
information
destroying top-secret classified special
access program information they're all
crimes deleting 33,000 subpoenaed emails
Crime acid washing bleach bit hard
drives crime that's obstruction bashing
devices with hammers obstruction so you
have struck in Page literally putting
the fix in along with Kobe and
apparently McCabe and Loretta Lynch all
new and they're talking about the need
at one point for a special counsel to
investigate Clinton's emails on March
18th struck rights thought of the
perfect person and Deacon bounces off of
page as who and responds Pat who's
senator Grassley says is Patrick
Fitzgerald the Special Counsel remember
in the Valerie Plame affair he's the guy
that put innocent Scooter Libby in jail
or got him a guilty plea in that case
and you got to give me some credit if we
go with him and delay briefing him until
I can get back and do it in other words
with his own prejudice his own point of
view his own spent late next week or
later he says and then struck says later
I could work with him again and damn we
get blank done and page follows up with
I know like I said we discussed boss and
him yesterday and on May 13 2016 page
follows up on the idea she says to
struck hey forgot to ask if you
mentioned the whole Special Counsel
thing to Andy we assume that stepping
the FBI director Andrew McCabe now what
struck and page are doing here is
stunning and here's why struck had a
massive massive role in the entire
Clinton email probe he oversaw the
interview with Hillary Clinton and her
top aides long after they wrote the
exoneration and page as you might
remember was McKay's
legal counselor and they're both saying
special counsel is needed which means
that they had doubts that the FBI would
do a real investigation which they
didn't do now Senator Ron Johnson also
made news this week releasing text
messages on May 19th struck appears to
be talking about getting an offer to
join Muller's investigation this is key
here struck says oh my answer's no I
don't want to join that investigation
and then you know the lead division and
then I think wait a minute this may be a
case will be in the history books a
chapter much like you tell me about my
extra time in the field in all the field
cases would you trade it a million
people sitting and add and staff jobs
this is a chance to do it maybe the most
important case of our lives and around
30 minutes later struck ass page the
question an investigation leading to
impeachment he's the one that said
there's no there there so in this case
it seems like struck knew that Muller
was gonna try and impeach the president
and he wanted to be a part of history
but he didn't think there was any there
there go back to May 19th in the
exchange two days after Muller was named
special counsel struck says you and I
both know the odds are nothing if I
thought it was likely I'd be there no
question
I hesitate in part because of my gut
sense and concerned there's no big there
there so struck who served he was a top
intelligence official at the FBI he
signed the papers to start this phony
Russia investigation and he's saying
that he knew from the start that Muller
would be carrying out a witch hunt he
didn't know if he wanted to be a part of
it and revelations about former attorney
general Loretta Lynch and her
involvement in the Clinton email server
cover-up now it's June 2016 remember
Bill Clinton he meets Loretta Lynch on a
tarmac there supposedly talking about
grandchildren for 40 minutes which
causes Lynch to say on July 1st that she
was you know literally stepping away
from the investigation and she would
accept whatever the FBI concluded now
keep in mind all of this is before
Hillary Clinton's interviewed that
happened on the 4th of July weekend
three days later
so after Lynch's statement is she's
gonna step back here
let the FBI decide she'll go along with
what they decide after she met with Bill
Clinton on the tarmac well-struck he
writes back to page timing looks like
hell talking about Clinton and Lynch
meeting on the tarmac Paige replies yeah
awful timing and page later adds it's a
real Profile in Courage meaning Loretta
Lynch since she knows no charges will be
brought here's a problem no decision was
made four days later well three days
later Hillary's interviewed four days
later Comey holds his press conference
spends thirteen and a half minutes
laying out the case that Hillary Clinton
should be indicted and at the last
thirty seconds of that lets her off the
hook so you have struck in Paige and
Lynch and Andrew McCabe and James Comey
all apparently knowing Clinton's never
going to get charged and the Obama
administration put the fix in the
corruption here if you're a New York
Times writer is unprecedented you should
maybe be covering a real story because
when you put it all together
here's what it all means you have
Hillary Clinton we now know fix the
primary against Bernie Sanders or I'll
use Donna brazil's word rigged it then
struck call me lynch McCabe others they
all put the fix it that allows Clinton
to stay in the presidential race they
don't want to rock the boat they want
her to beat Donald Trump so they're
overlook the crimes the obvious crimes
with the incontrovertible evidence
Clinton and the DNC then they try to
influence the election with a bought and
paid for twelve million dollar Russian
dossier full of Russian salacious lies
and propaganda and the Obama
administration they took the dossier
they weaponized the powerful tools of
surveillance and intelligence and then
use the phony dossier to get a FISA
warrant to target members of then the
Trump campaign and later the incoming
president if this isn't Watergate on
steroids and every single person
involved not investigated and not
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law we have shredded our constitute
because you have powerful Obama
administration officials in the FBI in
the DOJ clearly trying to circumvent
what is the will of you the American
people because they did not want Donald
Trump to become president we can never
let this happen again and the only way
to do that is to make sure we get every
fact every bit of truth expose it to the
American people and those people that
committed crimes need to go to jail the
key players need to be exposed now which
is what congressional Republicans
they're trying to do they've been
fighting to release the memo release the
memo some of them you've been helping a
lot you in this audience and what do we
know from that memo that will be
released probably next Wednesday or
Thursday we are told that will show
severe FISA abuses against the Trump
campaign and the president-elect and his
team and Fox News is learning that memo
is going to be released likely in a
matter of days it is imperative keep the
pressure on keep calling your members of
Congress demand release the memo the
number of your bottom of the screen will
get through two oh two two two four 3121
you've got to put the pressure on them
tell Congress release the memo we
deserve to know the truth and while
they're at it
release all fifty thousand text